so we got to start with the blockbuster
here you got stafford you got golf
flipping teams the rams are willing to
give up two first and a third to make it
happen
as simple as it gets who won this trade
in your mind's eye
matthew stafford that's who won because
if you think about it this is a guy
that's gone from a losing team now he's
at a winning team he's going to play on
natural grass sunny california
he's playing with a top defense it's
just so many different factors if i'm if
i'm matthew stafford i am the happiest
man in the national football league
because i get a chance to leave detroit
get with some real offensive coaching
and um they got weapons they got a bunch
of different things but it's got to be
matthew stafford jack
i feel like mcveigh better hope that
you're right because they they have made
some mistakes here at the quarterback
position talking about the rams as a
franchise first mistake was trading all
the way up to go get jared goff doesn't
wind up being the guy
the second mistake and to me this is the
bigger one
is paying him after his third year it's
a first round pick so you have five
years to wait and see wait and see then
you can give him that fifth year option
wait and see again to pay him after that
third year put them in a really tough
spot and that's when you end up just
wasting two first-round picks and this
is a team this is a franchise that
doesn't have first-round picks to waste
so at this point i feel like mcvay i
feel like that front office is betting
their futures betting their entire
careers on the fact that stafford is
that much of an upgrade and maybe he is
in this system but i think in that you
know in that way of thinking
you're blaming all of the issues
everything that went wrong nothing on
mcvay nothing on maybe his system
getting caught up with a little bit
you're just putting everything on golf
and maybe that's the truth
but they better they better prove they
can win with stafford quickly because
this this roster right now is not
exactly in perfect shape they need
weapons too there's things that they
need and whose fault is it jack whose
fault is it you said you you wouldn't
put it on um you know whose fault is it
then
where where would you place blame
i think it starts over some of it for
paying them after year three
yeah it's the organization you think
about what this organization did they
basically admitted that they were wrong
look what they did to brandon cooks they
paid brandon cooks 50 something like 50
million dollars you look at todd gurley
they signed them to i think it was a
four-year 60 million dollar deal with
like 45 million guaranteed like you
can't make mistakes like that on those
big contracts and
they've actually gotten a reputation
around the league that says you know
what if you want to get paid and go for
two or three years and make 20 30
million dollars just go to the rams
because they'll pay everybody and like
you talked about it i was going to
mention the same thing what made them
go to jared goff early and say we have
to pay you 134 million dollars there's
nothing that i saw that would make me as
a general manager or coach a guy in the
media go to jared goff and say i'm i'm
willing to pay you 134 million dollars
it's absolutely crazy
well it's the same mistake that we saw
with carson wentz in philadelphia is it
not it's the exact same thing i mean
they just they saw a couple good years
of it they said well this the trajectory
of this needs to be perfect as we go
down the stretch let's go ahead and
invest in it now
and you just don't need to i feel like
the secret to the league really is
having a quarterback on the rookie deal
for as long as possible filling up
around them and going to try to go win
games in that window and if he exceeds
if he becomes a top 10 or a top five
quarterback through that stretch okay
great pay him but if he doesn't
then there's no reason to and there's
certainly no reason to pay him before
you know the answer to the question and
and so that to me is the mistake but now
you're talking about going seven years
in a row without a first round pick i
mean you look back in 2015 they take
todd gurley 2016 they trade all the way
up give up a ton to go get jared goff
and now you're gonna go seven years in a
row without a first round pick you're
giving up a third round pick this year
as well man they don't have a lot of
resources to make this roster better
they're they're just betting everything
on the fact that stafford is this much
of a upgrade from jared goff and maybe
he is maybe he is
but i don't i don't know who he's
throwing the ball to that's the
what pieces does he have in la that are
so much better than what he had in
detroit that makes you say okay now he's
a super bowl winning quarterback is he
gonna go be able to beat green bay is he
gonna go be able to beat the bucks and
tom brady next year i don't buy it right
now i just don't buy it
i just think you talk about the weapons
for um matthew stafford and you got
robert woods you got cooper cup you got
two really good tight ends um
you got sean mcvay who's committed to
running the football so i i don't look
at it as as though you know he went to
la and all of a sudden he doesn't have
any weapons he has different weapons
these are more possession type guys run
after a catch they make you miss an open
space they're going to run the football
it's going to be some play action passes
and one thing that sean mcvay felt like
he wanted to do more of he wanted to
throw the ball down the field but of
course jared goff wasn't very good
throwing the ball down the field matthew
stafford is excellent at throwing the
ball down the field but also you think
of matthew stafford and he's a guy
that's been in a system where he's
holding the ball for a long period of
time and all the pressure everything
falls on matthew stafford time and time
again
you know now he doesn't have to feel
like he has to do everything he has a
number one defense he's got weapons
around him and he's got a really smart
offensive um mind and sean mcvay who's
still trying to figure out things so
when i look at this is there an upgrade
of matthew stafford over jared goff i
would say yes in one area i would say
well two areas i would say throwing a
ball down the field and toughness and
that's one thing that they you talk to
anybody about um matthew stafford
they'll always tell you how tough he is
but the one question i have because i
talked to someone that's been around
matthew stafford for a long time
and i asked him about the leadership
that's one thing that we've never heard
anything about matthew stafford and his
ability to lead he tells me and quote he
says calls him a vacant presence
doesn't have the type of leadership that
impacts the entire team
at times could be a selfish guy
i'm just saying and i
it didn't come from me i don't know
matthew stafford like that i know he's a
tough guy i've called him tough many
times before but this is the reason why
whoever i talked to told me that they
can't ascend to the next level because
of matthew stafford i i don't know
and from the same token what must have
happened to golf and mcvay's
relationship
uh you know who i've spoken to within
the rams organization sounded like there
was a bit of a disconnect between work
ethics between the two i'll leave it at
that a bit of a disconnect and i think
that started to rub on their
relationship a little bit
and to see them break up in this way
the other thing i heard was that golf
found out the same way the rest of the
world found out about the news
so that tells you something right for
him to find out and i understand adam
schefter is absolutely ruthlessly good
at his job and he gets ah so far ahead
of these things sometimes you know they
didn't have a chance to go tell golf but
for him to find out that same way lets
you know that this thing was just
pulling apart pulling apart they start
woofered over golf i mean it was just
slowly tearing apart the seams and i
think mcvay was ready for an alpha at
the quarterback position you know what i
mean like i think he was ready for
somebody who didn't have to just coach
to the last second every time he got to
get into his ear kind of hold his hand
he was ready for somebody who could take
coaching to another level take it to
another height and he viewed stafford as
that guy i would have liked this trade
if they did it for aaron rodgers for
stafford 32 years old missed eight games
in 2019 we've seen him get banged up
your left tackle and whitworth is 40
years old i mean how much longer can he
keep playing at this level
man you are betting a lot on somebody
who has not done much in the playoffs in
matt stafford i understand that they
haven't been great but he's had a lot of
years to make something happen
and you know it's amazing to me that
they will come out and say they'll give
up so much for matthew stafford but yet
they would not say hey we're going to
rip up the contract and try to work on a
new three or four year deal if this is a
trade only for one or two years it's it
wasn't worth it you know what i mean it
wasn't worth it to give up two
first-round picks give up your
quarterback that's been in your system
for x amount of years give up the third
round pick
i i just think that's absolutely crazy
man um
i i don't get it and i don't agree with
it um but
when you do look at
everything from
the lion's perspective
okay i'm gonna ask you when you're jared
goff and you leave la to go to detroit
like what is the what are the positives
there
there are no positives
there's no way there's no way around it
like mcveigh kind of did golf dirty a
little bit here like he put him into a
franchise who's in about a five-year
rebuild they're kind of going into the
las vegas rebuild mode here like this is
not gonna be quick you sign the coach
you sign coach campbell to six year deal
because you know it's a bit of a project
that he's taken over and golf as a
quarterback that most people view as
somebody who really was just in the
position he was in terms of the super
bowl because of mcveigh calling plays
and you removed that from the equation
so now it's just golf on a rebuilding
team in detroit as a cali kid who went
to cal who just bought a house in la and
you ship them to detroit
you tell me what the positives are man
hey he did him dirty he didn't i'm gonna
tell you what the positives are jack
i'm i'm gonna tell you and i think
number one the pressure is off the golf
because he gets to play in detroit he
gets to leave the bright lights of la
you gotta understand just because you
were first round a first pick or
whatever
everybody's not meant
or built to play in front of the bright
lights everybody can't handle the
pressure so now he can go to detroit
he's in the nfc north he's going to be
the third or fourth best quarterback
there depending on if you like mitchell
trubisky or if you like him and they're
going to continue to lose and it's going
to take time and i know dan campbell
can't say hey we're going to bite your
kneecap we're going to do man those
young kids they're not looking at
listening to that crap i have a 17 year
old son and if i tried to coach him like
that he'll look at me like that we don't
respond to that type of stuff so he's
totally way off base
um out there in detroit but that's
really i mean and he's a younger
quarterback and he has playoff
experience he has won more playoff games
than matthew stafford he's played in the
super bowl even though they lost so he i
mean he's a young quarterback he still
has a ceiling um he showed it at
different times that he's capable of
playing i still think that jared goff is
can still be a good quarterback nothing
great because he's not a special talent
but i still think he can be a good
quarterback
and rodney i gotta circle the wagons on
one thing from last week too because you
were thinking stafford may be a good fit
there in new england we've heard
throughout the course of this week that
he won't he would basically go anywhere
except for new england what was your
reaction to hearing that
it didn't surprise me because you look
at a guy like tom brady and he has so
much respect from all these guys across
the league patrick mahomes just all of
they admire tom so much and matthew
stafford is looking as if tom brady is
the greatest quarterback of all time and
he spent 20 years there and you can't
keep you can't keep tom brady happy and
tom is a very humble guy and you know
blah blah blah um he's probably looking
at that and saying you know i don't want
anything to do with it but also think
about it this he spent his entire career
playing at least eight games in the dome
he doesn't want to come out and play in
a cold with new york buffalo and and
well maybe miami but you know
all those all those things come into
play um with these quarterbacks
i i do think that you're going to see
the rams make some moves here
additionally and the nice thing about
being in la is you're able to get some
old heads some guys that have made some
money to come there and to finish out
their career chase some rings really
just more than anything enjoy being in
la marvin jones jr is a really
interesting one for me i i bet he ends
up as a ram i think he's going to want
to be in la he already made 40 million
bucks playing in detroit he's close with
stafford he's from long beach it's just
like everything to me seems to add up
there i i bet he goes there you don't
think so why not
because they don't they don't they can't
pay him
they can't pay him they already pay two
receivers eight figures
so where's the money gonna come from you
got money invested you got 100 million
invested in the corner you got 100
million invested in a defensive line
like where's the money coming from they
need help on the offensive line they're
they're starting to age on an offensive
line
where's the money coming from
that's that's my that's that's that's my
my point is that he's made his 40 mil he
wants to go home he's got about 17 kids
it's one of the cutest families you ever
see in the nfl
he's like i know marvin and i know
marvin is going to want to be in la and
i think he's going to want to continue
to play for stafford and i think you
throw you start to layer in being able
to play in a mcveigh offense they're
going to have to get somebody like that
if it's not marvin jones they're going
to have to convince somebody that
spending an entire football season in la
by the beach is awesome they're going to
have to just slowly start to convince
people just like new england does come
here win a championship and do it for a
discount they're going to have to figure
out how to start getting the la discount
because if they don't this is not a
championship roster right now they need
to make more if they're going to go beat
green bay go beat the bucks go beat
whoever else emerges next year in the
nfc because they're they're right now
just
you know there's a team that's ten and
six and winds up getting knocked out
round one or two in the playoffs in my
mind but you're missing one important
point the most important point
when you're toward the latter part of
your career as a player
the last place you want to go is to la
to california because you don't want 50
of your money gone
i was there from 94 to 2002 and i
couldn't believe the cost of living
you know and it wasn't like i was living
like a king i had a three bedroom
townhouse that i bought for about two
hundred thousand when it was first being
built and i eventually sold and made
some money but it's a very expensive
place to live it's like living in new
york which i couldn't do because it's
just so expensive you know and and you
talk about older players coming there
older players don't want 50 of their
money they're trying to they're trying
to you know keep the last bits and
scrapes of their of the money that
they're making so i think that's a big
factor and
you know like
i don't know how many people would break
down the wall to play with matthew
stafford i just
i'm just i just don't have a lot of
confidence in them like that jack
we'll see we'll see i mean it's it just
feels really reckless that's that's what
it feels like from the ram standpoint
and it may work you know you could bet
all this stuff on quarterbacks and but
it always seems to me like in the nfl
there's a really big difference you know
when you start getting down to
championship weekend divisional weekend
there's a substantial difference between
a really good quarterback and the great
quarterbacks and the question now is is
stafford a really good quarterback or is
he a great quarterback and for his whole
career he's been a really good
quarterback can he become great with
mcveigh and that would be really the
answer of whether or not these guys all
their careers survive because they have
no picks left i mean they literally have
no picks left after this jack he hasn't
been he now know it harder than the la
rams they just keep doubling he hasn't
down on every mistake that's all they're
doing
brother let me get in and say something
to you bro i'm trying to let me get in
go ahead matthew stafford you talking
about matthew stafford
oh you know about jared goff at this
point oh yeah
i was talking about stafford right there
okay and what was your main point with
stafford that you just made
my my main point is that he's been a
really good quarterback his whole career
can he become a great quarterback can he
compete head to head with rogers can he
compete head to head with brady if brady
has a better team around him than he
does
i don't know i haven't seen that did he
compete with did he compete with aaron
rodgers
when he was in the same division did he
compete with aaron rodgers when he was
in the same division
when was the last time detroit lions won
a division that's my point like matthew
stafford everybody talks about he's a
generational talent where
where is the generational talent at
like
everybody's telling me how great he is
he's great he's got a big arm he does
this he's tough okay he's tough but what
about the leadership why hasn't he won a
playoff game if he's so good tom brady
is so good and we saw that with the new
england patriots oh he can't win without
bill pelicek he goes to bruce arians in
tampa now he's in the super bowl
it's just everybody talks about how
great of a quarterback he is
he hasn't won a freaking playoff game
win a playoff game then come back and
tell me how great these quarterbacks are
people love to just blame it on detroit
that's that's like the company tag line
with staffers like ah but it was in
detroit all right let's just throw that
stuff away he was in detroit and and
we'll see he didn't have to be in
detroit he could have took that monies
from somebody else but he wanted the
money so he stayed in detroit where he
didn't have a lot of expectations he
didn't have a lot of pressure because
he's playing in detroit that's my thing
like he didn't want to it wasn't like he
was saying hey put me on put me in
philly put me in dallas put me in
somewhere where you know every single
week we're gonna get a whole bunch of
attention no he wanted he wanted to stay
in detroit
who wants to stay in detroit he's going
to play football for the lions
he's going to get attention now he's
going to get everything he bargained for
now that's that's for damn sure i'm
excited to watch it play out i am
there's so much pressure on mcvay
there's so much pressure on stafford
they can go attack this thing together
and we'll see let's just leave it at
that no pressure on golf backs though
and no pressure on golf there you go and
no pressure on golf that's well put
mahomes tom brady i want to start so
let's start with my homes against this
bucks defense when you think about that
matchup mahomes and the bucks d and this
bucks defense been flying around lately
todd bowles we saw what they did to the
green bay packers without bacteria now
you're talking about no fissure no
sports that match up what goes through
your mind
well i'm i'm looking at
number one is how do they stop tyreke
hill and that's the big big question
because you know in the first game i
think he had
269 yards i think it was 13 um catches
269 yards will they keep a safety over
top will they keep two safeties back
will andy reid will he be patient enough
to run the football to try to force that
extra safety in so they can't keep two
safeties back and protect the wide
receivers
if i'm todd bowles my number one goal is
to limit the big plays make patrick
holmes go 10 12 14 plays up and down the
field see if he can't turn the ball over
make him go the long hard way anytime
you play against kansas city make him go
the long hard way the one thing that i
will say
when you're watching this game jack
could you put me back on jack so i can
see him please
the one thing i would say jack when you
watch this game
when tyreek heal and you see all these
other guys coming off the line of
scrimmage just watch and see if the
bucks jam them if they slow them down if
they're afraid to play man-to-man if
they stand zone but the number one thing
i want you to watch is if anybody's
slowing them down because as the more
film i watch on kansas city
no one jams them no one slaws them slows
them down no one jams tyreke hill he's a
4-2-40 so you're gonna just let him run
his 40 40 yards down the field and run
past the safeties no you got to get in
the way you got to jam him you got to
hit him you got to slow him down those
are the little things that you have to
do when you play against kansas city and
you talk about the two back up you know
the two back up offensive tackles with
jpp jpp didn't even know mike remembers
he didn't even know who he was
he didn't even know who he was and to me
i would have went up to jpp if i was his
teammates like dude you got to know
everybody like why are you just knowing
the first team you got to know the
second team but
just a different story but yeah
let's let's hear that let's let's exact
that exact bite you're talking about
because it's listen we get into super
bowl
a little extra fire a little extra
motivation let's hear from jpp on some
of the backup tactics there are two
great chief stackers there are just two
starters these are two great tackles
fisher and schwartz here is jpp on the
backup all pros
yeah jason's wondering what your
thoughts are on mike remembers and uh
when you face a backup like that you
just go in expecting a bunch of more i
didn't even know who that was man a lot
to you but
this is the tackle that you're talking
about yeah i mean like i said i don't
uh i don't too much care about it you
know they got they got to figure that
out and i'm going to play some great
football this weekend
yeah jack and basically what he was
saying is like look i'm a baller they're
all pros and their pro bowlers are gone
i don't care it doesn't matter who you
put me against i'm gonna ball out and
ain't no backup gonna beat me that's
what he's saying that's what he
basically said so he's sitting back
chilling like
mahomes you well we cannot wait to get
after you but one thing about andy reid
and i played against andy reid since 94
when he was out in philly and he does a
lot of screens whether it's tight ends
running backs wide receiver screens he's
going to have a lot of screens a lot of
draws a lot of trick plays to slow down
um that defense and i i just like to see
him commit to running the football like
he did against buffalo remember this
year when they ran the ball against
buffalo and ran it down buffalo throat i
want to see if i'm to use cloud edward
solaire to do that
good luck i mean good luck like this box
defense is hard to run on like let's
just be honest like devon white is nasty
in that run game and uh you know and
dominic and sue's been great shaq
barrett's been great pierre paul's been
awesome like he was great in new york
he's been awesome in tampa too he's an
older guy now 31-32 still playing at
that really elite level
i have a weird feeling about the bucks
rodney i have a weird feeling that the
bucks might might just shock the world
in this game and i it's it's in large
part due to the two missing tackles but
when i went back and watched week 12
that game
this is with fisher with eric fisher
they got a ton of pressure on the homes
and you don't see that often fisher gave
up this is going up against shaq barrett
he gave up a sack fumble in the red zone
that the chiefs lost and the way that
the bucks defended the chiefs in the red
zone in particular that's typically
where the chiefs are so damn good they
always have a way of getting seven they
weren't getting seven in this game and
they held them to 27. if they could keep
it at that number or you know 27 24 my
guess is tom brady is able to beat that
on the offensive side of the ball
well also you think on offensive side of
the ball you look at a b and to me a b
is the x factor i mean this is a guy you
know when he was healthy he was
basically becoming their number one guy
they were getting him the ball on jet
sweeps and little tosses quick outs and
they were just getting him the ball
making him a priority and i just if they
have him he is such a problem because
he's fast he's quick he catches
everything that's near him and so much
attention put on mike evans and the deep
ball that antonio brown has the freedom
and the ability to kind of work the
middle and think about gronk gronk is
such an unselfish player i mean think
about last week one catch i mean well
when they played he had one catch it was
a screen for 29 yards and he did a heck
of a job blocking but this is i'm with
you i'm actually
picking
tampa bay because tom brady i can't bet
against tom brady he's responsible for
two rings i got on my finger so i
i feel you bro like tampa bay doesn't
have a lot they don't have to have be
nervous they don't have to have a lot of
nerves anything like that they can just
come and play with freedom because
they're good and they know they're good
and they're playing with a lot of
confidence
and patrick mahomes seems like he's been
playing it you know maybe i'll call it
80
85 sometimes it looks like 70 percent
like sometimes he
cuts on it or tries to really crank it
up and then you see him limp his way
back to the huddle it doesn't seem like
it's drastically affected his play so
far but my worry is okay so he's not
quite as cocky with his athleticism
those top level cuts that he has that we
sometimes see from him where it's like
oh damn like he has those sort of like
maybe a level below lamar jackson but he
has those elite athletic moments we
haven't seen those since he's had the
foot injury so if pierre paul if shaq
barrett if sue that's that's the other
one and dominic and sue can get pressure
from the inside if they're getting
pressure all over the face of patrick
mahomes and he has to crank it up to
that top gear
can he i don't know the answer to that i
haven't seen that in a month so can he
reach that top level if he can't he's
going to get sacked like this bucks d is
damn good he will get sacked multiple
times and that'll be the difference in
this game how would you try to shut down
tyreek hill he went 200 plus 269 203 in
the first quarter back in week 12.
i'm playing i'm i'm
if i'm the defensive coordinator i'm
playing more of a boxing one on them i'm
taking my smallest most athletic guy i'm
putting on on putting him on tyree kill
and say i want you to jam him and follow
him wherever he goes
and
we'll work out the rest of the details
in the secondary whether we're planned
zone whether we're playing man but this
is one guy and we're gonna always have a
safety favoring to his side you cannot
let him get deep and any time he catches
the ball he comes across the middle he
catches the ball you got to punish him
you got to hit him clean you got to hit
him fair you got to hit him hard every
single time he catches the ball
and then see what happens after that
okay so let's flip it because this is
interesting because we're talking about
the kansas city chiefs now this this is
it's an all-star team this is just an
absolute all-star team in the nfl
but we're both having an intuition an
intuition about the tampa bay buccaneers
and about tom brady so let's flip it to
that side of the ball and you know
people people were taking their shots on
tom brady recently through a pair of
picks in the most recent game against
green bay through a pair of picks also
is a 27-24 game week 12 when these two
teams met the first time and brady threw
a pair of picks in that game also i'm
just thinking if he doesn't turn the
ball over if we get one of those clean
brady games like we had been seeing
before green bay
they're going to be able to light up the
scoreboard like tom is starting to look
really comfortable with what he has
around him in this bucks offense it's
unlimited evans godwin scotty miller he
loves scotty miller that's that's the
one thing i'm like so when a b comes
back
what does that mean for scottie miller
because that's been one of brady's
favorite weapons all year even pre a b
entering the lineup he has loved scotty
miller i'm afraid they may lose that i
got i don't think they should lose that
because brady's got a lot of comfort
with the speedster
well i'll tell you this don't forget
about kansas city and their defense um
defense coordinator steve spagnola he
played against brady in 2007.
he was the defensive coordinator of the
new york giants that when we were
averaging 37 points on offense he held
us to 14 points he did a great job of
disguising blitz and brady had him
uncomfortable had him confused and we
didn't know what the heck was going on
so this is a veteran defensive
coordinator he knows how to call certain
calls in certain moments because he's
been in those moments he's been in the
super bowl he's been in championship
games he knows he understands and he's
not afraid of tom brady he took brady's
heart in 2007 and he's done a wonderful
job this year and let's face it the
kansas city chiefs they're not the most
talented team but they play good defense
they play well together and they have
guys that changes
that will change the complexion of the
game so i look at steve's magnola as
much as we've been giving todd bowles a
lot of respect and a lot of props steve
spagnola is that dude you know with
chris jones and and tyron matthew and
those young cornerbacks and guys coming
in and out i think he's done a fabulous
job this year
i'm glad you said that because it it's
it's become the forgotten piece
everybody talks so much about both these
offenses then todd goals and what the
bucks defense has been able to do
becomes the defense that gets the praise
in in the spotlight and nobody talks
about the chief's defense and spagnaw
has been able to get those stops in key
moments just a handful of those stops in
key moments and we'll see if he's able
to do that again let's hear from brady
because now everything's being made
about you know there was always this
crowd brady needs belichick brady
couldn't do any of this stuff without
belichick let's hear from brady on his
former coach who the
six rings together here he was
i have a great relationship with him and
uh
again i'm just incredibly grateful for
uh you know what he's meant in my life
as a coach
and
i
he was everything you could ask for as a
player and uh you know i love my time i
had two incredible decades
there and um you know my football
journey took me to a different place and
i certainly could never have
accomplished the things in my career
without
his support and his teachings
and
incredible coach and mentor for me and
i've had a lot of those in my career but
obviously he's at the top of the list
bingo and that's exactly what i was
talking about and that's exactly what i
told you last last week i said for
people that compare and say is it more
brady is it more belichick belichick and
i said tom brady would not be in this
position or bill belichick wouldn't be
in the position that he's in one without
the other and tom brady just said it and
i will tell you this now you see why so
many of his teammates they listen and
they fall in line with tom brady because
that's the type of leader he is very
unselfish he's very appreciative the
words that he use was grateful what he
meant
um
and i couldn't accomplish it without him
those are the terms to me that's a
humble leader we don't have many
superstars matter of fact he's the goat
he's the greatest quarterback to ever
play and yet he's thanking coach
belichick on a basically on the eve of
him going into the super bowl that's
what you get from tom brady so this is
this is what i've gotten for six years
when i played with tom brady that's the
type of confidence and the type of
leader that we we knew was going out in
the fourth quarter to win us the
football game when tom brady jogged on
that football field and i broke my form
and i was in there getting x-rayed i
knew tom brady was going to take us and
and lead us to victory to get that super
bowl ring this just really pumps me up
because everyone wants to make it about
bill versus tom and tom versus bill when
when both of those guys both need one
another period
rodney he wins this ring tom brady you
said greatest football player
he's the greatest athlete to ever play
he's the greatest athlete if he wins
this ring number seven to go to tampa
after winning six in new england to go
down there to tampa in year one and go
do it again without belichick which was
really the only knock anybody ever had
on him is that he had the greatest coach
ever so that's what why is that a knock
you still gotta win that's you still
gotta go out there and throw passes you
avoid interceptions coach belichick
can't do all that
of course but it's you know it's back to
that mcveigh discussion mcveigh and golf
you know i mean everybody everybody
loves to come up with some narrative and
that was the only thing that you could
ever put against brady that's the point
i'm trying to make because i won those
six together but for him to know if he
goes down there and beats mr superhuman
superhero patrick mahomes in his first
year with the tampa bay bucks people
were clowning on him people were
clowning on him for going to town are
you going to tampa you talk about going
to tampa you're going to get smoke down
there man then the cam newton's going to
go up to new england he's going to go
win a bunch of games like that's that's
the next wave you don't go to tampa at
43 years old he goes to the super bowl
year one if he wins this thing
for my money he's the greatest athlete
period to ever live i wouldn't say aptly
because no one's gonna ever mistake my
boy tom for an athlete all right jack
so don't call him an athlete he might be
the best football player but he's not
the best athlete have you seen this guy
walk oh is he not an [ __ ]
he's so clumsy the way he was
well listen he's not going to win the
100 meter dash in the olympics we got
that you know you probably can't even
play pickup basketball
but dude that guy's open listen tv 12.
he's got the hit mobility he's got the
pliability in every direction that's an
athlete in modern day listen nascar
drivers or athletes tom brady's an
athlete give me a break brother i agree
with you i'm just giving my boy a hard
time that's all i agree with you
i love it i'm going to send him this
clip soon as we get off i'm just kidding
i don't know
let's get to this too because this one
this was an interesting one here with
the offensive coordinator because you
know when he first went to tampa one of
the most interesting pieces of the
puzzle was that byron leftwich was going
to become his offensive coordinator
byron left was like 41 years old right
so he's younger than tom brady those two
have played against each other a bunch
of times it was just an interesting
pairing down there in the success that
they have had instantaneously when you
put them together boom it's been perfect
bruce aryans wanted leftwitch to get
some head coaching looks now in his
second year as offensive coordinator
with the bucks what say you
i would say um
you know i heard this and i
i just didn't know if byron was ready
right now at this point to be a head
coach
like
that's big i mean it's it's one thing to
coach and to mentor a guy that you
played against and that's two years
older than you
but to command the entire attention of
the entire team i i don't know give him
one more year he should start you know
with some opportunities
um
but we saw what happened to eric the
enemy and he definitely wasn't going to
get an opportunity before eric being me
i didn't think that was going to be
possible so we'll see what happens but
we've had this discussion before we see
and we know how wrong it is but at the
same time sometimes you just got to be
patient
and they may be able to put together a
couple runs together there you know like
left witch brady this is not it for tom
brady this super bowl run is not it i
think he's going to 45 so they may have
two or three left they're not hitting
quarterbacks anymore that lifespan is
it's it just keeps getting longer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports